his arrest is now officially a matter of
public interest
footage of marcus kutan restrained on
the ground with a police officer's knee
on his neck
mr kuttan denied the charge of
possessing a knife in a public place
a magistrate agreed his case should be
sent to the crown court for scrutiny
it was the manner of the arrest
essentially
a metropolitan police officer used
techniques which are
not approved by the metropolitan police
including
putting a knee on his neck which meant
that he couldn't breathe
this mirrors the same arrest technique
that was used in america for george
floyd which led to his tragic death no
justice no peace
just over a mile away outside islington
police station
the black lives matter movement took a
stand in support
that police officer knew what he was
doing that police officer
knew how dangerous it is there's been
enough protest there's been enough to
you know talk about how dangerous that
is
just sickened because they stop and
search but not the way they were doing
it i've never seen something so it's
being done like that locally in my life
a lot of the time you just see yourself
or people you know
in that situation one officer has been
suspended another removed from
operational duty
while the police watchdog investigates
the image of a police officer's knee on
a suspect's neck
has inflamed tensions all over the world
and it happened here
again on this street raising the
question once more
about the use of police force here in
the uk
in court the restraining technique was
described as excessive
even if the suspect
or the arrested person was
resisting with two officers
um there should be no reason whatsoever
that kneeling on a person's neck should
enter their minds
for these peaceful protesters it was
another call for change
for the police another video raising
difficult questions that need to be
answered
adele robinson sky news islington